well I get paid for the scrap metal vote
yeah the same thing I didn't think of it
how much scrap metal how much scrap
metal do you have please nice ya know
all the same as ever yeah yeah do you
plan to would you like to donate your
body to science yeah but I if somebody
can take the methlen yeah that's a good
idea I must put it in my Testament they
can take it off haha no cremation would
you do that donate your body to to
science I haven't even I haven't gotten
that far what i have done is write a
testament actually uh because i watched
the documentary about i don't know if i
should say this the gosh oh okay and
then I just basically wanted to make
sure but that's how far i got into my
own death mm-hmm but if I sleep here use
whatever you want what I'm gone rindge
no don't do whatever you want oh yeah
maybe I would yeah I love guy I'd love
to help if that I just haven't gotten
that far one of your recent books and
you have several books out in
Scandinavia now and in one of them you
celebrate this science of forensics yes
why is that so important to justice well
I think over the last 20 years the
development of forensic science has
meant that we have much stronger
evidence in many cases when the case
comes to court so in that respect it's
easier to convict criminals of crimes
that previously might be very difficult
DNA for instance DNA is one of the key
element earth yeah yeah and all sorts of
cases are now being solved from you know
20 years ago or more cuz of the DNA
possibilities for example yeah yeah it
but specifically what what what stores
let's take our bones which you both have
stopped you have some left yeah yeah
what stories enough to make Sylvia what
stories can they tell well our bodies
are full of secrets um you know we think
that all our secrets are on the outside
but actually saw men
of our secrets are on the inside the
long bones of your thigh for example if
you if you subject them to analysis it
will tell us where you've been for the
last seven years let's say you know you
spent a few years in Sweden you spent
six months in Canada you spent the rest
of the time in the South Seas how is
that possible it's possible because
everywhere you live the the earth and
the water and the air have slightly
different composition and scientists
have analyzed these and they can say
from the composition of these elements
in your bones and apparently that and
this is the one that always sounds like
magic to me the bones in your ear are
formed when you're in the womb and
unlike most of the bones in your body
they don't renew themselves over the
course of your life so the small bone in
there's a tiny born in your ear that was
there when you were in your mother's
womb you have to be dead yet hey um and
if you analyze that ball yeah it will
tell you where your mother was living
when she was pregnant with you that
isn't that magic I haven't figured that
where your mother I understand also that
insects are very important in six can
tell a lot right now insects are
fascinating and a fly can smell a dead
body from a kilometer away story hmm
what do you find what if you find a body
without limbs uh-huh how can you get the
full picture well this is see people
think they're so clever my friend Sue
black always says you know mother is
easy the hard part is disposing of the
body and sometimes people think they're
being clever cuz they cut off the arms
and the legs so they get rid of
fingerprints and any identifying marks
on the feet so you don't even know what
size the feet are but if the body had a
tattoo as a net there's still evidence
in the torso because when you get a
tattoo on your arm see you have these
lymph nodes in your in your armpits you
of lymph nodes in your groin when you
have a tattoo the lymph nodes absorb
some of the ink from the tattoo so even
if you cut the arm off the pathologist
can cut open lymph node and go
or he had a tattoo on his right arm with
green and yellow and blue ink can't tell
you the picture that was on the tattoo
obviously can't tell you if I said mom
but you can tell the color well you can
tell you can tell which colors you can
tell which arm looks like not that just
been why do you say and you can say he
had the tattoo on his left leg on the
hot blue it was a tattoo of blue ink do
you have a tattoo yeah I have a stupid
one here Oh what is it it's you want to
know why I have it yeah well yeah I
don't really know what it is it's uh no
just something dumb it's there to remind
me not to make stupid decisions when I'm
well it's the dumbest tattoo ever I
regret it doesn't mean like it's I think
we should lower or is it this is a diet
the usual woman and I wanted to get out
like a whole sleeve and then I got this
stupid little tree and then I regretted
it so it will just be there yeah it will
be any dumb decision so you have in your
armpit I have same color of it you have
the ink in your armpit and the lymph
nodes in your armpit sure sure it's good
to know yeah but that was the reverse
side of the coin of your body taking up
the ink from the tattoos is that if you
if you're trying to fool the authorities
that a body belongs to somebody else and
you you tattoo it post-mortem so that it
has the same tattoos as the person
you're trying to pretend is dead and
there won't be any ink in the lymph
nodes so if this ever happened well one
of my stories it happens Val McDermid
thank you so much for being here with
this some pleasure thank you toggle
thibault Val McDermid